okay hello everyone welcome to another W
from language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series although I actually have to say
that this topic doesn't seem like it's
really related to that but um
looks like we're looking at diff tools
here can we try and dispatch this one
here this data set bottom space thing
because it looks like that's a yeah
that's that's pretty trival
straightforward
issue right so this
was right so this was something you
requested and you know that did not
reserve the space
underneath and so it doesn't reserve the
space
underneath and the only change is right
that little hover thing used to not have
a border and we decided since it can Now
cover have I don't understand what does
the data set do in the case where there
isn't a thing that says other here I
don't understand what's what does data
set do if it's a PL the the the only
point being that the other is there so
you can see it being covered up okay but
if I do
this then then then then then it will
bleed go into next cell potentially into
the next cell yes
yes okay why is it the case that when in
the hover
um that I'm not seeing a hover when I'm
to the right of that content
there I don't know that we have a really
good answer to that that was something
that we looked at and it has something
to do with T's original implementation
and we don't entirely know the answer to
that uh so I think I think it should be
the case that you get this hover
whenever you're in the cell right
whenever you're in this data set cell it
doesn't require that you're on top of
the content to get the
hover um uh that that makes sense to me
and um so we can we can definitely look
into that it's just it it might not be
the easiest thing to
implement um okay well I think what's
there right now is not super useful I
have to say the the the the problem is
well I mean let's be fair this is the
worst case scenario you know because
those things are tiny um yeah I get it
you might not even notice if those
things were bigger yeah but but the
problem is you need to you need to have
uh a box to attach the hover effect
to and if uh if you're looking to fill
out the contents then you need to
introduce like a pain box or something
like that and then that leads to
okay but then how are you going to Auto
siiz well it's it's more about once
you've introduced pain boxes then does
column sizing work in the same way it
did before or does it have KnockOn
effects that are
undesirable right so so is this just a
consequence of of T insisting on sort of
a minimal column width can we well I
guess that still might not do I mean it
it it's to wrap a pain box around
everything what's non-trivial is setting
the size of the pain
box that's that's the hard part in in a
way that works with whatever logic is
auto sizing The Columns right
now
um so I there there you know there might
be something that will just work but I'm
not confident not at all confident all
right okay so do can I ask should the
keys also be clickable anywhere inside
the cell or should you have to click on
the
key you you you you just sent this out
as an example right I don't know
yep yeah I mean that seems wrong that
that doesn't work that it only works
when you're under the content area so
both have the hover and be clickable
yeah I think so
okay I mean
I see the clickable the clickability
okay the question of whether the whole
cell should be clickable as opposed to
just I kind of think that there's a
question of should the so whole cell
light up when you're in it or should
only the content area light
up yeah it looks a little strange for
the font to be changing colors but then
have that key to Mouse over of the whole
region that would look a little strange
I agree I agree with you so it's not
obvious what we want to do I I would
argue that
um
uh you know I'd argue that the whole
cell that there is a that that we could
have something where for example the
border of the whole cell lights up when
you're in
it so the right click Behavior doesn't
require you to be right or maybe it
does uh
okay I'm not seeing that see I'm I'm not
seeing that right click if I go there if
I hover what the hell why isn't that
lighting up when I'm
hovering why why should it light up
that's data I mean what why should it
light up no but look at this look at
this look at the right click here okay
the right click here does not give
position doesn't let me right right th
this is this is a consequence of the
same same issue this is pretty
horrifying you know also just as I said
for dealing with attached cells I mean
same thing for the context menu you have
to have a box to latch on to and yeah I
get I get the implementation issue in
the way it's done right now I I'm I
think this isn't right I mean I think
that shouldn't be different I think I
should be able to find the location of
that cell
you know and honestly as soon as I go in
the cell I would like it to show me
that's the location of the
cell yeah I I I I I definitely agree
that that would be uh desirable you know
I'm not going to promise that on any
particular timeline because I don't know
fine this is not for this meeting
offline have a think about it see
whether there's an easy way to do it and
ux wise to me lighting up the border of
the sell your in seems like a good
idea can we Light Up The Border I I
don't know I don't
know
the yeah I too much to say for this
meeting I I I can we can talk about it
well we'll have a private meeting with
John and and yeah right but I mean I
think the the the particular question
you're asking it's a win what we've got
here now I think looks really good I
like the Border I like the Border
independent of its you know the reasons
why we had to have that border I think
the Gorder border is a good thing
okay um I mean the fact that I might go
and try and click down there and then
it's gone by the time I get my mouse
over there is
unfortunate but that's the way it is
that's the nature of of hovery type
stuff
yep okay let us let us go
Diffy okay um
right so we had a meeting right well we
we had one meeting in LCC and I think a
dedicated
meeting and
so um yep that's allowing you to get the
the latest version yeah so you are so
this meeting will be with the same
version of diff tools that anyone can
get from the P repository today
great uh okay
all right you have to warm me up because
I've a little bit forgotten where we got
to last time okay let me see what that
does diff of
that right so that used to return a
summary box that you would then use diff
viu to visualize no it used to return
just a completely naked list with some
red and some green oh that's right and
and one of the things that we had
decided in the last meeting was that we
wanted some sort of chrome around the
output okay so I think that Chrome
graphic design wise I think it's a bit
too
big and too heavy which is why Billy is
here right and I'm also totally
mystified by the list colon one edit
what does that mean it means that it's
detected that you're comparing lists and
that it has seen one edit and the edit
is changing B and C to D okay first
point the fact that it says you've got a
list well I can see I've got a
list you see what I'm saying that's your
internal I hear what you're saying yeah
so it's it's more obvious here it's less
obvious for other kinds of things that
you're
diffing okay I think we gotta find a way
to so and this is a good example um you
know uh the when you're diffing strings
you can diff by character by word or by
line
okay okay no I'm not necessarily
defending the the current presentation
but I think we do need something I I
don't disagree but I think the best
thing to do would be if I've got you
know diff the cat was on the
mat the dog I'm going to put that in the
dog was was on the
hat okay so that's a character
level thing and May and maybe maybe do a
copy down and is it the third argument
Lou uh it's an option which diff
granularity What is it
called diff granularity Arrow quote
words okay okay all right so to me if
we've got this chrome and you've got
this word here you might as well have it
this be a pull down where you can select
do I want characters or words or
whatever maybe
not keep in mind this isn't just a view
this is an object no I understand well
okay so so first point here
is okay so the first thing we're talking
about here is this thing is an object
who normal
form
spero what should that
do clearly I don't I don't know but you
can you can do iner form at least
actually maybe it's more instructive to
copy that output and paste it into an
input
cell um because this is another key
feature uh oh right that's the bug I
reported last night no copy that cop
this is this was supposed to work um
okay what what should I do it was
supposed to have
seen put your cursor in the percent
seven and start
typing and and and out of seven yeah or
out of whatever out yeah one of these
outputs I see so it minimalizes there
yes for better or worse and and and you
know and also helps
to uh you know give you confidence that
this is indeed a computable
object
yes okay all right I mean clearly this I
don't know how this font ends up being
bigger than this font here just seems
crazy but that's just a
detail make
sense that is detail yes
yeah
um Okay so
I mean I have another question which is
pres the color scheme for what's first I
mean like I I don't know maybe it's just
me
but I see red means you're removing from
this is the removed things and that's
the added thing green means add red
means removed this this is very
standard okay I mean you know the the
the Shades might be slightly different
from one place to the next but but the
use of red and green uh is unfortunately
for color blind folks extremely standard
uh we can reset it if we yes yes we can
and and uh I think L do you have a
preset color blind theme or I don't
quite have theme support spun up yet but
once that's accessible then yes there's
one waiting to spring into action I just
don't quite have the pipes done
okay
so uh all right let's let's take a
look I mean I want to come back to this
because there's things I I want to see
what your um what happens for
notebooks can I see that
somehow or even a whole cell how do I
how do I see that sure so one thing you
can do is you can go to the pallet
menu and bring up uh the go to there
should be a diff tools submenu about
halfway down and there's a compare cells
pet
okay how does that work right so you
click on one cell that you want to
compare and you know click you say then
click on the you selected cell and do
that for the other and voila you get
okay so let me consider a use case that
I might actually have
right so so you you can just do it just
to see it work you can do it real quick
with the N9 and n10
cells th those those would be sensible
inputs okay so I hit this use selected
cell I hit this I say you selected
cell and now
what oh I see it just took a while to
come
up is this really
scalable what you have
here from cells and so uh it it's I mean
yeah it's it's going to struggle with
giant cells
yes what does it do with graphics
currently it does nothing special for
graphics if I make a disc you know three
discs that are in the same place and one
of the diss in a different place do we
have any hope of being able to indicate
that in a sensible
way the next thing I was intending to do
was to diff IM Graphics as as images as
bit Maps I haven't yet thought about gra
diffing Graphics as you know sets of
I I I don't think that uh doing any kind
of vector diff in the way that you're
imagining Steven can possibly be in the
remit of something we would ship uh for
the next release yeah okay I
me yeah we can certainly diff the Box
Expressions yeah I don't know how useful
that is well in some cases it is
actually right and and right I mean if
it really is two
diss you know if you're comparing
something with two discs and something
with two discs right I mean the the
boxes are practically identical to the
input form of the graphics and so I
would think that in that particular case
that would actually be pretty useful
because you could just see oh the
coordinates of the second guy are
different now if you're going to diff
two outputs from plot which is ginormous
then yeah that's hope
and and also plot is not engineered for
uh you know something that looks like
reproducibility across uh a range of
inputs I mean you know it may make
decisions to do something radically
different based on inputs that don't
seem radically different right yeah and
and Stephen if you want to try this I
think you can just you know create the
two input and then wrap them in
expression cell and diff them and that
will give you the cell diff that you
were uh thinking of yeah okay but but
let let me let me just understand okay
so a use case that I would have is I've
got two versions of a thing I'm writing
and they have certain diffs
mhm
and what would I typically want to do I
would typically want to take those diffs
and for example accept or reject
diffs we have a mechanism for doing
that I that's not something I've gotten
to yet it's obviously something I want
um to have the ability to to we have
applying all of a particular diff as as
a sort of single patch object from one
expression to create another expression
I don't have you know
take I want this one I don't want this
one I want to reverse this one uh that's
not something I've built yeah so so
basically we've been spending some
Polish time but the Polish time has all
been on the diff side not on the merge
side I see but so so what you imagine is
that one of these diff objects has
essentially a stream of micro diffs is
that true right we we they're they're
typically called hunks in the diff world
each change set is called a hunk
okay but so so do we have I mean if I
say hunks you
know if I one day would I be able to say
hunks of a diff and it would give me a
list of hunks or hunks list or something
at the
diff uh that's reasonable yes and that
would give me a bunch of other diffs
basically which are the the micro the I
mean one one of the things that we
definitely want to do is have some kind
of algebra of diffs you know a way to
split up and merge and and otherwise you
know sort of transform uh sets of diffs
right so so I mean roughly what we're
looking at
here let's think about this for a second
I mean you
know each we thought about this a bit in
the last meeting and one of the
conclusions we came to or tentative
conclusions was to to work towards a
diff modify function analogous to
molecule modify that would be able to do
these sorts of
things would it modify the diff or would
it because right Mo modify Mo modifies
the molecule not the modifier of the
molecule correct so there'd be other I
mean there'd be interactive gestures for
applying the modified diff but if what
you really want is to modify the diff
directly then I think a diff modify
function is a fine thing fair enough but
I mean I
think I
mean somehow to
me I can imagine a couple of scenarios
so I'll give you an example editing
stuff
okay I might have a long
document somebody might have read it
there might be 10 typos in the document
it's a long 100 page document only 10
typos are left I don't really want to
scroll through the whole document to see
those 10 typos rather what I want to be
able to do in our environment would be
just get me the list of those 10 typos
with their context and I'll just click
through and say accept reject etc those
things and then I want to take that
collection of of diff like things and
apply that to my original
document does that make sense
yeahh
um now and by the way something else
that you might want to do is you might
want to annotate the diff um yes indeed
you you instead of directly applying it
yourself you're kind of you know having
a conversation with someone else who is
also you know uh consuming that diff
object okay by the way have you guys
seen the the whole blog tool system
that's been built for me over the past I
don't know 10 years or something I
pieces of it but you should get a demo
because it has a bunch of relevant stuff
from
whom I think I don't actually know who
built it maybe Jay warolf built it I'm
not sure um Mark long would certainly uh
is a is a big user of
it I'll reach out to
them uh
I do think by the way that that th those
tools with a few very specific you know
things that have you know SW comment or
something as a as a um as a piece but
those tools should probably be
palletized and or put in wfr so we can
so people can create them um those kinds
of things because that that's been I I
would say that that mechanism well you
should see how it works you should see
how it works it's pretty good I mean
it's been it's been gradually finded
over about a 10year
period
um and in some
ways you know if the if the goal is
editor makes suggestions on a notebook
it's probably pretty well optimized for
that and it's not obvious that this is
that what you have here I mean what
needs to think about how that what you
have here merges with that does that
make sense that that's certainly not in
our primary Mission um I mean our
primary mission is to you know to solve
a bunch of core problems
um about code or
what well about a variety of things uh
but you know one of the big ones is uh
uh notebook diff and notebook merge in
in a fashion that is going to be
friendly with uh uh with Version
Control
yes uh but but that's not the only issue
um you know certainly I I have you know
in the past I have
created uh you know oneoff diffing tools
because you know I uh I have these you
know in my case it's often because I'm
looking at bugs that have to do with
cells and I have two cells that are
mostly the same except where they aren't
uh or two expressions that are mostly
the same except where they aren't and I
need to I need to see the pieces that
actually are different but it's like a
huge
tree
um right okay let's keep going on what
we've got here because I think
um the case
of sort of
the the you you should look at these
blog tool things I mean and you know
it's a slightly different case than
probably you've been considering it's
the case where
you
know rather than two people having work
time it's like one person is the author
another person is the
editor which is not the usual code case
right usual code cases different people
are working on the same piece of you
know same file and they they modify
different parts it's it's peers yeah
right
um now you know I would and and it's
also historical it's you know it's
archaeological uh as well that that is
that is certainly one of my Prime use
cases is what is to see what it was what
the code looked like at one point in the
past yes either either what what it
looked like or when that first came into
being and why yeah if if if the person
wrote a useful commit message although
oftentimes with the code I'm working
with I I get to Rory MOG initial commit
so I know that
commit oh that's the original commit in
the source system yes that's
funny
uh okay
the um funit fun bit of History Rory was
like boss number four for me I think in
the company interesting okay the um no
somebody should tell him that we still
he's he's still seen in the
um in the archaeology um okay in any
case
the uh what was I going to say here
so we were talking about like code
archaeology and the difference between
that and the authoring
story right okay so the other you know
the case of word processors and change
tracking and word processors
that's much closer to the thing that
we're doing with editing of of notebooks
so to speak yes that is
correct
and in the World At
Large to what extent is kind of like I'm
going to write my documents in in git
type thing with Git and have multiple
people working on it versus I'm going to
do it in a word processor where it's
going to have change
tracking how do people view those two
things and I I've certainly heard of
people like a decade ago I heard of
people everybody was enthusiastic oh
we're going to use git to do all of our
you know uh collaborative editing type
stuff I I I think it depends on on the
field and the kind
of in the conventions in the field I
mean like for example it it's my
understanding that uh uh legal folks are
you know I don't hear of some uh you
know math movement to plain text and and
diffs and that sort of thing you know
they're they're as far as I know f are
using change tracking in word or
comparable word processors and they're
very happy with it yes that is my
impression also because because the
typical thing is
that there isn't usually contention in a
single
document see what I'm saying in other
words it's like person a modifies it
then person B puts it that changes then
person C puts in that changes yes um or
if if they do diverge then there's they
know they're diverging and someone's
responsible for you know opening the
various copies and synthesizing them in
some
way right whereas the case of
programming
where you know I don't actually know why
that's so different
because I why is it different I
mean it's because the pieces of code
yeah it's kind of funny because in a
document right it could be the case that
somebody changed an interesting point I
mean in a legal document for example it
could be the case that somebody changed
the definition at the beginning of the
document and the truth is that that
should blow up a bunch of other changes
that were made but nobody knows that
right whereas with code it's just not
going to
work right it won't even compile right
well or you know sometimes you in the
worst case scenario you end up with
something that compiles but introduces a
sneaky bug fortunately that's rare but
it does
happen
right
um right Sandra is commenting that
sometimes these uh things that have
simultaneous collaborative editing are
useful um yeah I mean I I see that from
time to time I mean yeah and I yeah I
was also going to say I think the the
legal folks you know tend to be more
templated right there's a template for
you know this kind of document and then
you know you fill in and
tweak for whatever whereas in code you
know typically you need to write
something for this feature right which
may be a completely standard thing but
you still need to you know write it in
this language in this code
organization to make it fit so that
feels you're saying it's written more
from scratch I don't know some legal
documents are written from scratch but I
think I mean
in I mean okay there's a completely
separate path and I don't know how that
relates to all of this which is the
collaborating collaborative editing
effort in the cloud
I mean collaborating editing effort
collaborative editing on the desktop
we've actually had experiments with
using the channel framework and so on
right 10 five 10 years ago right but but
I think that's a weird case that I don't
think people really want that is two
people have notebooks I mean it's funny
how this is evolved because the very
existence of Zoom like
things has made it less important to for
example be able to stream notebook
content I don't know why because what's
that yeah I was going to say so you know
my impression
is uh right I because quote unquote
collaborative editing is either
sequential so you know person a writes
something and then sends it out to their
colleagues and then person B says how
about this and then we review and Etc y
or or people you know if it's really
more simultaneous or or asynchronous
then people will be using some you know
Google Docs or uh you know ior cloud or
whatever it's called the these days um
because I I I I have I have serious
doubts as to whether anyone actually
does literally simultaneous stuff I mean
I I suppose I can envision
Corner cases but I think you know these
you know you know these platforms for
simultaneous editing it's really much
more about lowering the friction of
taking turns yeah you know if if if if I
don't have to save and send it to you to
take a turn if I just have to if if if
you know I I you just take the
opportunity to say here let me jump in
and fix this you know right by the way I
mean is almost free things like Dropbox
don't even bother to try and do merges
right they just say it's
conflicted
I that's certainly the case for for
nextcloud I I don't know that I have
enough experience with Dropbox I I I so
they don't do merge at the content level
but there is a merge problem they have
to solve at the file level sure um you
know a f
appeared in in one client and was
renamed in another client and now what
to
do
right
um let's see right but i' I've certainly
run into the problem where you know I
was on a plane and edited something in
in nexcloud and then I landed and
discovered that par had edited or
whatever you know for appropriate values
of Carla and um you know and then it
just yells at me and says you know I
need to do something to fix
this
so
um
interesting boy somebody on our live
stream complaining about my uh
microphone which surprises me um but uh
you sound fine fine to me
likewise
um
okay
so well all right I mean just just a
separate issue which is in the cloud we
are certainly working towards a
collaborative editing story which will
probably be a sell-by cell collaborative
editing
thing and I don't know how that relates
to any of
this
I mean for example storing the
information on who edited what when
which I'm not sure how much we were
planning to do that but that symbolic
structure might as well be the same
structure I mean I'd like to remind you
sort of cautionary Tale in quotes the
the um the story you know what I
insisted got put in I don't know 15
years ago or something now of cell
change times
data we now have at least to wfr that I
think Lou wrote that gives you the
symbolic structure of the history of
your notebook right
mhm
yes I mean I'm not sure if I've used
that I've certainly used it in the past
with some
hackin
uh that's kind of the notebook
archaeology story presumably and and to
be clear it's not the history of your
notebook it's it's the it's the history
of when content was either created or
modified so it's it's like time it's
like time series but it's it's not
including the content of those
changes okay but I mean what I can
imagine is that your Calculus of diffs
could be something that could come out
of that that is I could ask the question
you know how was my notebook built
that's essentially the git history
question of you know how is right yeah
and you know there have been uh you know
various ways that people have uh used
git to analyze source code bases to
answer big picture questions about how
code evolved um and yes in principle
with this sort of thing one could build
those tools to be useful for notebooks
as
well right but so what I'm saying is in
terms of how these things fit together
one could imagine that one could take a
notebook and one could say make a hunks
list for this
notebook in
principle between two different
revisions no no between between between
the big bang and where we are
today notebook creation and where we are
today yeah that's a series so so between
in different revisions and
GS I guess so yeah yeah yes I mean it
could be a this was the state at this
time and I mean
clearly and this relates to the
wonderful world of multi-way systems and
so on you could have these and that
that's where for example in the these um
what are they called CRTs these um oh
gosh what is that it's a this data
structure
crdt maybe so what does that stand for
yeah conflict 3 resolution data type yes
I mean that's one of its use cases is
these collaborative editing
environments and that relates to to this
question about if you look at the graph
of all histories you know do you have
these conflicts in that
graph um otherwise known as ranally
separated events in
physics uh okay let's let's go look at
some more of this this stuff so first
question is the graphic design here and
this just really heavy weight as far as
I'm concerned I mean the main event
should be whatever it is you're seeing
in the actual diffs and this stuff up
here should be really light and Billy I
think that's just a question of I mean
change the font size maybe gray it
down
[Music]
um okay I don't know whether it needs to
label itself as hello I a diff because I
think it's pretty obvious from what what
it is
um I
think that arguably this should be a
cool down for the C for the for the
characters versus words case I am
unconvinced that this there are three
edits here is
important well it it I mean for this
case on unclear but for larger cases I
mean it's giv you an idea of just how
many differences are there what what you
know quantify it in some way so in the
100 page document that you were
mentioning earlier with 10 changes yeah
that's that's a useful that would be
useful right it would be even more
useful if I could jump to and and and
and there are three kinds of changes
that it's going to flag a change might
be an addition a removal or an edit
indeed welome and breaking those out is
also handy information it's kind of the
indel versus you know
substitution yeah right uh I Would by
the way I would put the edits if you're
going to list these I would put the
edits first four edits one edition not
one edition four
edits okay
Point
um and maybe you should say one
insertion one
deletion that might be
clearer see what I'm saying that's
reasonable yes y especially is that you
know follows the bio informatics
nomeclature as
well um no I have no problem with the
word insertion that's fine
okay I wonder if we need if the graphic
design is such that um I don't know
whether these
are I would assume that that should be
space character space alignment
there well right now just displaying the
actual you know string the in input
string I know the unreviewed input
strings yeah I I think that for this
pull down they should be plain English
type stuff if we're going to do it as a
pull down like
that if it's plain English then are you
removing the capitalization and if
you're removing the capitalization then
is that going too far and strain from
what the imput form would be I'm not
sure I don't think it does I I think
that people
I think if we have the right autoc
completion when you're actually entering
it it's probably okay but
um I really hate
this um what do you hate
lists ah okay yeah I you know to be
honest I'm not the happiest with it
either but I you know I haven't spend as
much time maybe as I could thinking
about how we could present that
information um but I think we should
present it in some way
but what about the summary box rendering
between in13 and in8 in your notebook
the fact that that mentions lists up top
is that similarly
distracting I think by the time it's a
summary box it's kind of
incomprehensible
anyway I'm not as bothered by
that look I think what we want to
do also this isn't right because this
isn't right this isn't the right there's
another problem here this says the unit
of steephen yes if we take you know if
you copy
in13 and then you put
the the the then no no the the input
above mhm and you put
strings uh you know you put strings
around each of those two
inputs
yeah okay but I have a more serious
problem just a second it's a very
straightforward problem this is not list
this is list element it's the
granularity of the thing that you are
diffing yes it's it's not quite list
elements it's more sequences there's
there's an a sequence that has been
edited okay okay so so if I were to do
for example here and this is made a
little bit more clear in the summary box
if you were to open that summary box um
you would see that how the hunk is is
presumed to
be okay so let's take range of 10 here
and then oops then I want what I want
there
is okay that was separate list elements
that wasn't a
sequence it could have said the sequence
was
removed yes it's possible there's a
disconnect between counting of removals
and Counting of
edits
I should say three deletions anyway much
clearer but that's that's irrelevant I
mean I think here let's say we go um you
know 654
here I'm maybe you really want to do
ABC something that's completely
unrelated
two yeah that's three edits that's uh
try instead of ABC try try delete the
C and see what it
does yeah this seems like it could do
better there's something not quite right
here okay so let me let me comment on
your algebra of hunks or whatever
clearly there are that it is not obvious
there are many forms given that you have
certain
operations you know if you have pure
single element insertion deletion
substitution it's Unique but if you as
soon as you allow sequences there isn't
an obvious canonical
form see what I'm
saying I don't understand what you mean
by canonical there there are multiple
ways that one could could right as soon
as you have sequences as we we see in
this case there are multiple
representations for one
diff right one overall diff could be
represented as you delete this then you
add this or you could represent it as
you delete the sequence you add the
sequence etc etc etc but is that fatal
in any way I don't think it is it's not
but those two are different things so
think about the notebook case when we
have a cell now we know cells Providence
because we have expression U IDs we know
if a cell has been edited or cell has
been
added fine so it's I I understand the
point I'm making is in your Calculus of
hunk I would expect that there is some
simplify function in other words it is I
don't know an important point right it's
there's no there isn't an canonical form
so in general
correct okay so there are multiple ways
that can be represented and you know to
me
the here are a bunch of it's sort of an
interesting case
because it reminds me of the sort of
combinator type apply this thing apply
many boy it's it's it's weird because we
we also in principle have operations
like
this yeah I mean there's some data
structures where they work like lists
there somewhere they will be a mess like
even arrays or matrices you know you
can't just go willy-nilly and say I want
to remove this block in this Matrix and
um you know you you get in the case of
lists you can just remove blocks and the
the there'll be a reasonable thing that
you get out from it in the case of a 2d
data structure you'll get a thing with
holes in
it which is a whole different story I
mean that's in sense what we're dealing
with in Geometry anyway never mind the
um okay I'm
I'm okay so this this next item has to
do with I understand what it is
yeah I would think that appearance would
be the
better what do you think I mean the so
there are two different things these are
doing right one is show me the diff
without the
Chrome and the other is show me the diff
with the Chrome but start the Chrome at
this
view yeah and what's this that that is
the proposed that is the proposed thing
that should start the diff with chrome
at a given view instead of I currently
have a third argument that either is or
isn't wrapped in a list and that's a bit
Whimsical and I want to get rid of that
yeah um so I thought the second the
second thing should be an option but I
appear is the closest option name that
we could come up with I kind of agree
sensitively I
agree um previously we had a third
argument that was doing way too much
work so there are some new
options we've already looked at diff
granularity I think
diff input function is just a
convenience for pre-processing the
inputs what do you mean by that I mean
that that is
for exactly it's exactly equivalent to
diff of uh characters of the first
argument comma characters of the second
argument
and then the string values and the next
couple inputs are just conveniences for
common Transformations input form string
standard form
cell well in other words you're saying
if I have x s with a with a superscript
what am I actually
diffing for example do I diff uh um you
know the inline cell whatever thing
right I mean you could right you can do
the experiment right there Square the
first X and you know re-evaluate and
you'll see a carrot in the first one and
in the second case you'll see sort of
cell box boxy
differences
MH
okay me just
uh right okay that's this thing which I
think seems a bit embryonic still I mean
this seems this is a complicated piece
of functionality yeah
um okay we should probably wrap in a
moment here
but
uh well let's see there's some minor
issues with this
chrome um is there any major thing we
want to still discuss with that before
we look for another I mean I I don't
like I think we should lead
with if we're going to have this thing
here we should say four edits one
insertion right as a leading thing
because it's kind of like gives you the
idea of what it is this the real killer
here was lists huh what does that mean
um yeah really that's an
annotation let's see four edits one
insertion as I say this is just the
wrong you know it's the wrong thing
because a list is the whole object and a
character is the granity concept m
so I mean that's more elements
um by the way Sandra is commenting what
about using the same icons as an icon
eyes not quite sure what that's for
but I think it's instead of the word
lists we have the iconized you know list
brace dot dot dot close I see I see I
see I see
interesting I don't think that
generalizes to the other types very well
though
does well I think in the list situation
I just
think look first of
all I don't know I mean I okay one
question is do you need to have a
display of what granularity it is
question one and question two do you
need to be able to change that grity
interactively here I think the answer to
that is probably no for the and in fact
I I really don't want to yeah because
then you have to you have to not then it
has to be lazy I mean otherwise exactly
and and and that's not the point of you
know in my view a diff object has been
fully resolved fully computed been diff
is it is the
output yep
so I think those are all good reasons to
not have
this and just have the view as just drop
the what it what it is and that's you
know they're just like saying when you
get the output 13 you don't annotate
where the 13 came from so to speak yeah
yeah
um okay I need to go to something else
but so big picture I to you know I'm
trying to drive this project to
something that we can ship in the next
release um and so that's going to
involve a number more of these meetings
doesn't have to be LCC but uh yeah I I
think there should probably be custom
meetings but
yes I agree okay gonna take a few more
meetings we we'll start by fixing up
some of the design stuff and a few of
the other things you mentioned and
iterate uh shortly after the holiday
sounds good to me looking nice good work
okay all right see y all soon okay
thanks bye
bye